es gibt nur einen Mann in der Ukraine
der das Ansehen und die Kenntnis hat
etwas zu sagen dass der Präsident noch
nie gesagt hat es ist Valeri saluschni
der Oberkommandierende und es ist
vermutlich die Wahrheit der Krieg steckt
in einer
Sackgasse seit zwei Jahren halten die
Menschen in der Ukraine die Folgen des
Überfalls aus saluschnis Erklärung ist
eine zesur ein Eingeständnis eine
Aufforderung und eine Botschaft an die
Welt und an die eigenen Leute ich denke
der Beitrag von salusne das ist ein
nüchander aber definitiv kein
hoffnungsloser Blick auf die Lage und es
ist weniger die Betonung dass die
Situation sich in der sackgase befinden
befindet sondern auch in konstruktiver
Vorschlag der aber aus meiner
Perspektive nützlich ist dass
Nüchternheit nützlich ist sieht Russland
komplett anders obwohl die Angreifer
gerade in diesen Tagen in der Schlacht
nah der Kleinstadt afdivka tausende
Soldaten verlieren lässt Präsident Putin
öffentlich keinen Zweifel zu am Kampf um
unsere historischen Gebiete der
Militäretat in Moskau in dieser Woche
beschloss umfastst 111 Milliarden Euro
75% der russischen
Gesamtausgaben damit macht er natürlich
deutlich mit der Erhöhung des
militäraushalts dass er für einen langen
Krieg sich rüstet damit will er den
Westen einschüchtern er will Schwäche
provozieren und genau das da der Westen
nicht eingehen im Westen zeigen sich
Risse das natoland Türkei z.B hilft
Russland die Sanktionen zu umgehen das
natoland Ungarn z.B verhindert dass die
EU die für die Ukraine gedachten Mittel
auszahlt in Deutschland streitet die
Politik ob es sich der Bundeshaushalt
noch leisten kann die Hilfe für die
Ukraine von vi Milliarden in diesem Jahr
auf 8 Milliarden im nächsten zu
verdoppeln der schnellste Weg zum
Frieden ist der Sieg der Überfallenen
also wir tun ja derzeit zu wenig damit
die Ukrainer die besetzten Gebiete
wieder befreien können die Ukraine wird
diesen Krieg nicht gewinnen das haben
wir immer gesagt und man sieht es
bereits jetzt dass die Ukraine diesen
Krieg auch nicht gewinnen kann die Hilfe
für die Ukraine aufzugeben das Land
aufzugeben kommt für die ampelregierung
nicht in Frage wir werden die Ukraine
weiter unterstützen solange sie uns
braucht und unsere Unterstützung darf
nicht nachlassen weil eineg Putins
katastrophale Folgen hätte wir setzen
diese Unterstützung fort so lange wie
nötig die EU und Deutschland sind im
Grunde kein so entscheidender Faktor wir
sind viel zu schwach um die Ukraine
alleine am Leben zu halten ohne die
Amerikaner sind die Europäer ein
Hühnerhaufen die Amerikaner haben der
Ukraine in diesem Jahr mit 20 Milliarden
Euro geholfen wie viel es im nächsten
Jahr werden völlig offen die
ultrarechten unter den Republikanern
blockier
die Basis unsere Basis unterstützt gar
kein Geld mehr für die Ukraine wir haben
Veteranen die unter Brücken schlafen das
muss Priorität haben in unserem Land
selbst mit Joe Biden als Präsident muss
die Ukraine mit weniger Hilfe rechnen
mit Donald Trump als Präsident kann sie
mit gar keiner Hilfe mehr rechnen zwar
behauptet Trump gewohnt pralerisch den
Krieg binnen 24 Stunden zu beenden aber
finanzil
Null seine Leute im Kongress machen es
inzwischen zur Bedingung dass kein Geld
mehr an die Ukraine fließt bei allem
möglichen also selbst wenn es darum geht
den Haushalt weiter zu finanzieren sagen
sie wir machen das nur wenn gesichert
ist dass nichts mehr an die Ukraine geht
mit westlicher Unterstützung oder ohne
westlicher Unterstützung also da gibt's
einfach keine keine Alternative und
keinen Ausweg als diesen
Verteidigungskampf hier weiter
vorzuführen die Botschaft saluschnis ist
auch ein Appell vor allem an Washington
aber auch an Berlin die Ukraine kann
überleben aber sie braucht Hilfe